(crowd cheering)
(relaxing music)
- I love this color on you.
It looks great.
- Thank you.
- I know, you look beautiful.
These are beautiful.
- Happy St. Patrick's Day.
Yeah, yeah.
- I know,
I love it.
Green is my favorite color.
- I heard through the grapevine.
- It's my favorite color.
These are beautiful,
and I'm not having seen
anybody take 'em away.
They're gonna stay right
here, they're so pretty.
I wanna 'em.
Meet Jay, have ya'll ever met?
- Yes. No.
- No.
- This my first time,
but I've grown up watching you
my whole life.
- Well, thank you,
I appreciate that.
- Obviously.
- Thank you.
- How are you today?
- I'm very good actually.
I'm very good.
I didn't bring anything.
I should have brought flowers.
You brought
- a personality.
yourself in one piece.
You're good.
- You're good.
(crowd clapping)
(all laugh)
So Novi, is it true that
your real name is Ashley?
- Yes.
- So why change it?
- Okay.
So at the time when I
was building my career
there's another woman named Ashley Brown,
who plays Mary Poppins on Broadway.
- Oh, okay.
- And so,
you know how it goes
and the you can't have
the same name.
- The same name.
- So I changed it and I
was trying to figure it
out 'cause my middle name is Taylor.
And I was like, "I feel like
that's like a lot to say."
You know, Ashley Taylor Brown.
So I was looking around,
and I was born in the month of November.
- Are you a Scorpio?
- Yes, ma'am.
- I am surrounded by Scorpios.
- Woo.
- Listen...
(crowd cheers)
- I love Scorpio's.
- We have things to talk about.
- All right.
- Yes.
- My sister is a Scorpio.
I love Scorpio's.
So wait, so you chose Novi
- Novi.
- for November?
- Yes.
- Oh.
- Yes, and I looked it up later
and it actually means "God's gift,"
which is super...
(crowd cheering)
Right?
I was like-
- Wow.
- That's good.
That's empowering,
I love that.
- Thank you.
- And so as Novi, you star on "Sista's",
right?
- Yes.
- So can you tell us a
little about the show?
Because it seems intense.
- It's very intense.
- Yeah.
- It's your soap opera.
It's basically "Sex in the city"
in Atlanta.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- And they have a lot of money
to throw on.
- A lot.
- 'Cause somebody just said
1.5, or something like that.
- Yeah, listen, and it's super fun
and obviously it's a
show about single women
and we need that.
- Yeah.
- We need spaces for our stories,
told our way.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause people be uncomfortable
with how women date
and love and things of that nature.
So it's just good to see it,
and especially our community.
We have Tyler Perry
- Yeah.
behind it, so...
(audience claps)
(audience cheering)
- Never heard of him.
Never heard of him. (laughs)
- Never heard, oh, no.
- He's doing all right.
Yeah.
- Yeah, a little bit.
- So I heard that you had
to audition for the show.
You were on a cruise?
- Yeah, I was on a cruise ship. (laughs)
- How does that happen?
Like...
- Okay. Well, I mean, obviously,
you guys, if you don't know
if you have artists in
your family, you know
it's a long journey.
And I was in LA for a while,
hadn't seen my mother in years,
and I'm a mommy's girl.
- Yeah.
- And a family friend
of ours put us together
on a cruise and said, "You
guys need to reconnect."
- Right.
- "Hang out."
I was like, "Okay."
Couldn't even afford the
da gone plane ticket.
But I was like, "All right,
I'm gonna go anyway."
- Okay.
- Go on the cruise,
and I get auditions, and I'm like,
"I'm just trying to take a break."
You know, I trying to take a break
from life,
- Yeah.
I wasn't booking anything.
Nothing was happening.
And so I got the audition,
and my mom's like,
"Just do it."
I was like, "No, I don't want to.
I don't care."
It was a commercial
audition and a TV show,
- Right.
- For "Sista's."
So we found a little
spot on the cruise ship,
but everybody's drinking,
there's loud music everywhere.
So I'm like, "Where are we gonna go?"
And it happened to be on the first day
that we walked around the cruise ship,
we found a corridor, with
a beautiful circular light.
So I was like, "Okay, cool.
We'll do the audition here."
- Yeah.
- Most horrible audition
I think I've ever done.
I did everything you're
not supposed to do,
go out the frame,
there's like certain things.
- Yeah.
- Sent it in, me and
my mom are at the spot,
and I'm having a breakdown at this point.
Like, I'm crying, "God,
when is it my turn?
I'm working so hard, I don't understand."
- Yeah.
- And literally
less than 48 hours
later my manager's like,
"You got a call back."
I'm in Rome,
- Ah, well.
at this time, in Rome.
- That's very boujee
to get a call back
- In Rome,
and you're in, yeah.
- While I can't pay my rent.
- That's very, yeah.
- It's so many things going on.
- You know what though?
Just hide that part and just
be like, "I was in Rome,
- I was in Rome.
- and I got the call."
- But that's the way it always works.
You know?
- Yep.
- I would go on auditions,
coming from New England,
I'd go, "Well, thank you for
having me in this audition."
Oh, and I'd read it and I'd
go, "Thank you, everybody.
I appreciate you having me here."
I never got anything.
- Yep.
- So one day I got a script
and I go, "This sucks.
This is the worst written thing."
I didn't even want to do it.
Well, you gotta go up.
I'll do it, I go.
So I go and I go, "Who
wrote this piece of crap?
This is unbelievable."
And I tell 'em how terrible I think it is.
I don't really wanna do it.
I go, "Hey, they called, they loved you.
You've got it."
(Kelly laughs)
I go, "What are you talking about?"
Because they're looking for real people.
I'm all, "Thank you very much.
Oh, I appreciate this opportunity."
This sucks.
Who wrote this piece of crap?
He's the one.
That's the guy we want.
- He's the guy.
- Yep.
Yeah, now you see what women are like
when we start dating men. (laughs)
It's the mean ones always get us.
(crowd laughs)
Anyway.
Well, I love you.
You bring flowers and astrology.
I love this.
And talent.